foreign
let's go to Marissa in Phoenix Arizona
where it's the fall but it's probably
still 150 degrees what's up Marissa
hey Dr John how you doing good how are
you
I'm good it is still really hot here but
like I there's a hurricane jacket last
night and I like made myself wet just
like feel like it was cooling down hey
you showed them way to go I did I said
that thermostat
is it that's it that's like a jean
jacket is December right I mean that's
like late February is or early February
is is the the depth of winter in Arizona
is a jean jacket is that right
yeah I mean you're probably right that's
that's not wrong
all right all right so it's good to talk
to you what's up how can I help
yeah so I have
a dating question
um and I wrote down like three kind of
bullet point question things okay um so
I thought maybe if it's okay I could
just read those absolutely ask whatever
follow-up questions you think are
relevant yes and just remember the last
time I dated was like a quarter century
ago so I'll do my best is that cool this
is yeah yeah you know I think that's a
fair
I am not
I wasn't good at it then but hey let's
figure it out we'll figure it out okay
go for it
okay so should I be concerned about
dating someone in recovery related to
alcohol
and what are some good boundaries that
we can set up early on to protect both
of our mental health and then how can I
be supportive of their Journey excellent
very cool great question so um tell me
about this person
um so this person is pretty new in my
life and maybe it'll work out maybe it
won't but my the reason that I felt like
it was relevant or not relevant but like
worthwhile asking maybe somebody that is
a professional is
um
I think I've only dated alcoholics
um and I feel like I've done a lot of
work the last couple of years I took
some time off dating
I did a lot of work on myself I'm really
nice to myself now I feel better than I
ever have and I recently started like
dipping my toes in the dating pool again
and it was like immediately the first
um like I was like
that's the thing like I feel so much
better and yet so out of the Potpourri
of humans I picked the one that is an
alcoholic so what what if you look back
in time so you've done some work the
last few years when you look back over
your life what has dating alcoholics
brought you because it's brought it's
definitely brought you tough stuff but
I'm I'm specifically interested in what
are the things that have brought you
good
I
have come to describe
to people that I've dated as like their
personalities Sparkle a little bit
differently and
um I think that's the most Pinterest on
a pillow thing I've ever heard that's
incredible
people who struggle with addiction
Sparkle differently that sounds okay so
what does that mean
I I think you know I haven't struggled
with alcoholism or Addiction in the
traditional sense but
I think some of the like darkness that
comes with
or the I guess the darkness that leads
up to choosing that as a coping
mechanism
um I feel like I can relate to that or I
you know what I mean like they usually
have a dark sense of humor it's funny
um they tend to be
um maybe not the life of the party but
maybe also not not the life of the party
you know what I mean like they're very
easy to be around
um
they're they're not easy to be around
their altered self is easy to be around
does that make sense
and so often when you fall in love with
somebody who's a chemical addict or
struggling with addiction to chemicals
right if drugs alcohol whatever
you fall in love with
there is a space between you and them
and there's comfort in that space
and I know what I'm saying sounds
woo-woo but I'm I'm super serious you
you are
um you are in love with the safety of
not having to fully integrate with
somebody else so much so that you're
willing to deal with the abuse they're
not showing up the lying the financial
infidelity all the stuff because I can
be in love with somebody and be in a
relationship with somebody and not
actually have to be connected to that
person because there's something between
us you see what I mean
I definitely think that that resonates
so did that come from your mom or your
dad
who where did the original Hurt come
from
both and then the subsequent step
parents I mean it was
yeah so you have a body that understands
relationships hurt
and you also have a part of your brain
that knows without relationships we die
and so you found it a a helpful Middle
Ground
I can be deeply in relationship with
somebody and then here's I I'm leading
you somewhere I can be deeply in
relationship with somebody and not ever
have to be all the way in because they
can't be all the way in because they
have wallpapered their lives with
alcohol or they've wallpapered a space
between me and them with you know weed
or cocaine or whatever they're using to
to hide from the world you see what I'm
saying yeah and so
laughs
then your addiction becomes and I tell
me again tell me if I'm wrong your
addiction becomes taken care of
you are going to prove that you're worth
being loved
by taking care of picking up
um saying it's okay drawing boundaries
and then letting them push on them a
little bit is that fair or tell me 100
100 accurate okay so you've done this
before you or every bit an addict as
they are
yeah Pia Melody calls it Pia Melody
calls it love addiction
you're addicted to being in love but
your body can't take being in love so
you go towards somebody who's an addict
so y'all can be in love together but
you're both in love with fictionalized
versions of yourselves
and then you try to solve it until it
blows up which it inevitably will
is that fair yeah
and now you've done a bunch of work on
yourself and you're ready to plug in
then
way to go yeah okay so you've got six
weeks to find this person through like
dating apps and things like that and I
was like oh
yeah I'm like Sober Sober though you
understand that right and I was like
oh okay so I I actually have don't have
any concern with like the idea of
somebody being in relationship loving
marrying falling in love with somebody
in recovery not a little bit I will say
if somebody's using actively then
marriage counseling is a waste of your
time
because you're not dealing with that
person you're dealing with that with the
addiction right so if somebody's sober
man that's the time
I wonder if your hesitancy is you
haven't been with you haven't been all
in with somebody who's
actually looks you in the eye and means
it
I agree with that like I am
like I was an only child I am terrified
of actual closeness with other people
um and
I like I want to I've I've worked so
hard
to be nice to myself and I
I want to protect that at all cost
um I don't I don't want to go blindly
into this and think like oh but this
time it's going to be different and then
it's not but but but but
your relationship can never work if
that's the way you enter into it
the challenge with relationship is or
the the devil of relationships is you
have to go all in
and when you go all in that means you
could get hurt again
but if you don't go all in
it never it never becomes what it could
be
and so you've done all this work you are
the Olympic gymnast that was almost
um going to the Olympics and then you
blew out your ACL and tore your Achilles
tendon and you spent two years in rehab
and now you are at the mats again
and they're telling you to go do your
Roundup flip-flop whatever flip flap
flippity flop things that gymnasts do
and you're standing there remembering
not being able getting carried off the
mats because you your legs had blown out
yeah you've done all this work and here
you are and the reality is you could go
do a round off flip-flop and blow out
the other knee you could blow out the
same knee
or you can go in a gold medal
foreign
do you see what I'm saying
yes I completely agree so if you enter
into this relationship and you go for it
you're gonna have to let him know
I am practicing being in relationship
with somebody
and so I'm gonna be awkward sometimes
and I'm going to be weird and it's about
me and it's not about you
that is your that is your entry point
into this
because you can and what I think is cool
about this is
um he'll have this he'll have the same
language as you
you were addicted to
uh alcohol I was addicted to rescuing
people
and so I'm sober too
I can't heal you I can't rescue you I
can't keep you sober what I can be is
the best girlfriend you've ever had in
your life
or that's not even true don't I strike
that from the record I I can be me
which I think is going to be the best
girlfriend ever
foreign
clearly stating what you need clearly
stating your boundaries
understanding when you start trying to
take care of him or fix him or solve him
that that's not your job
where is that line between you know if
somebody
in lots of therapy and group sessions
and all of those things and so like he's
actively working on learning
things
um so when he asks me my opinion on
stuff
where are some of those lines of this is
me trying to fix you or tell you what
you need to do for yourself versus if
you get invited
it's an invitation
okay when I see my wife walk through the
kitchen and in a certain way and I think
oh gosh she's in a bad mood
and I start looking around the house to
try to solve that bad mood what I have
done is taken her autonomy away I've
taken her personality away I've taken
her strength away and I have made it my
mission to fix her because she's clearly
broken she's not operating efficiently
right now
that's where I get myself into trouble
that's when I use the relationship I use
my wife to make me feel better about
myself
the other side of it is when I see her
walk through the kitchen I can get up
from my chair put my phone down and walk
over and get in front of her as she's
walking through and say hey you okay
and I let her answer and she's like no
no no I was just thinking about
something else cool I just saved myself
and all of us a whole bunch of hassle
because I was about to start trying to
solve something that wasn't even a
problem or she can say yeah I'm really
struggling with I miss my granddad who
passed away last year I missed this I
I've got to have a hard conversation
with one of my coaching clients she can
speak into it so if you are invited to
give your opinion give your opinion that
doesn't have anything to do with him
that has to do with you not thinking
your opinion's got validity to it
okay and it does
it never has before because your
opinions were a waste of time because
you're trying to keep addicts alive
and you're not doing that anymore
now your opinion's worth being your
opinion
and he might not like your opinion and
he may say I don't want to date because
your opinions are stupid
and then you go well I'm freaking
Marissa from Phoenix so that's my
opinion or let's then send me an article
and I'll read it and see if we can and
then we'll have a discussion we'll see
what I'm saying now we're talking about
relationship back and forth give and
take I think this well I think this
now we're in an exchange we're not in a
prop Meetup so I can prop you up so I
can prop me up so I can prop you up
okay
if you find yourself trying to solve
problems without being invited in that's
when you know
okay or when you see him hurting
and you feel bad
that's a that's an alarm
okay
because you're gonna rush in and try to
make him feel better and that can never
be your job
okay that makes sense
yeah it does
you sound you sound scared
um
I'm nervous I think uh
I think I am nervous I feel like
um I'm looking for the the glaring red
flags and I I can't I can't find them so
I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop
because nobody's perfect
um
so yeah I'm nervous do you hold on do
you realize you just contradicted
yourself okay
you really like this guy
or you like the idea of this guy
and you know nobody's perfect
and yet you're waiting for him to prove
himself not perfect
so there's no reason to wait for other
shoes to drop
they're already all scattered all over
the floor all over the house all over
the neighborhood
you're not perfect he's not perfect and
so y'all can choose to be not perfectly
perfect together
or you can choose not to be
but you have so much like physical fear
about being intimately connected with
somebody I'm not talking about sex I'm
talking about close with somebody
that you go in with so much hedging
I'm waiting for this I don't know about
this I'm worried about this well it
could be that just go
and be willing to say hey I I said
something last night I'm taking I get
take backs I get take backs I'm a
recovering addict I get take backs or
I'll be right over and then as you're
grabbing everything to run to his rescue
you stop and you text him and say
actually I'm already in my sleeping
clothes
um
let's get together for lunch tomorrow
I've got some time for lunch tomorrow
and then you're gonna feel that
maddening discomfort that you couldn't
run to the rescue you're gonna feel it
and you're going to have to practice
that feeling
and he's going to have to practice being
uncomfortable being alone being scared
being tired being exhausted and not
turning to alcohol and not having
somebody come run to save him he's gonna
have to learn to stand up on his own two
feet and then you're all going to be
practicing these things together
does that make sense yeah it does
are you seeing somebody still
um am I still seeing him about asking no
I know you're still seeing him gross I
can hear it like what about um what
about you
what about uh a counselor you still
talking to somebody
uh on and off today I haven't in a
couple months okay cool
so when do you have a date planned
yeah he's played pretty predictable and
reliable and chasing but not in like a
love bombing way and I feel like a dog
chasing her tail that like caught it and
I don't know what to do with it now
do you not like him
I do like him
I just don't I you know I was like oh I
want somebody like this right and then
you
have like a few I've never had like a
long list of they have to have I've
never had that but like these are some
of the qualities that I want in a human
and a partner
and then like
they're like oh here I am and I'm like
oh what do I do with it now
I'll say this word over and over I want
you just to to get this tattooed on your
forearm okay in the most basic way get
like one of those arrows over it or
underneath it okay actually don't do
this
um I grew up in a home where money was
scary
like the times my dad had to go to the
grocery store knowing we didn't have any
money but he had three kids I had to eat
okay it was tough
and I uh my car I bought for a thousand
dollars and I drove it for six years and
it was like a giant roller skate it was
so teeny
um and it was gonna break at any moment
and it just kept it was a Toyota so it
kept going it kept going money has
always been then I went and got myself
in six figures worth of debt like money
has always been a source of pain
and then
my wife and I got radical we paid off
everything I don't know anybody anything
anymore
and now I work at a job Dave Ramsey's my
boss he pays me takes care of us really
well and
I'm having to practice
not being terrified every month when
bills come in
I'm having to practice
um
spending money
does that make sense
yeah because it's a terrifying it's
terrifying for me because my whole body
says this all ends right now
and
I don't think that's true
it could it could all end tomorrow no
question about it and as my friend Todd
says I don't have a meteorite plan
like if that happens if inflation goes
to 500 and we're killing our neighbors
for water okay I'll deal with that when
that happens that's not probably not
gonna happen though and so
I'm gonna practice I'm gonna pay for
something I'm gonna feel uncomfortable
about it and I'm gonna feel that random
weird guilt for no reason about it
and then I'm going to enjoy it
and so you are going to go on this date
and you're going to look him in the eye
and you're going to say I'm a recovering
addict too so I'm practicing as well
so if I'm awkward or weird it's about me
it's not about you
and you are all the things I put on my
list but I also have never done like
I've never been with this list before
and so we're going to be figuring this
out as we go and you're going to keep no
secrets that way you can be as light as
possible you're not carrying a bunch of
cinder blocks around with you and then
all of a sudden
this might work
or it might not
but we're just practicing
because you're in recovery too and let
me tell you this Marissa
I'm so proud of the work that you've
done I'm so proud of the honesty you
have walking into this relationship
and I'm proud of the person you're gonna
become he's lucky to have you and if he
chooses elsewhere or you choose
elsewhere great
but if y'all get married I get to come
to the to the wedding okay cool deal